friends I just worked my ass off this
past week and I couldn't be happy about
that and I'd love to explain
[Music]
why hi there my name is Drex and I make
videos about po spinning and flow arts
and sometimes about my perspective on
the world too and this is one such video
but before we dive into all that I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fir Mecca flow fests flow toys
juggling calling pyro ter light toys
spinballs and Ultra for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all of these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- buus
friend of the channel Becca beonin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so the
context here is that about 2 months ago
I got it into my head to do something
kind of nuts and that is to take one of
my favorite POI performance videos of
all time that is G's uh poy performance
at San Francisco decom back in 2008 and
learn the choreography from top to
bottom uh I've had no guidance or help
from G I'm literally just reverse
engineering it from his video and I
decided to give myself one week to learn
his choreography and to perform it
myself which is just an absolutely
absurd deadline to put on a project like
that and it was really really hard but
I'm also super proud of the results and
FYI that video will be coming out
hopefully in the next week I have to
take some time to run through so much
raw footage in order to put that video
out to the world but uh be on the
lookout for it so the night that I shot
the final video for that project I
definitely felt a little disappointed in
the performance that I ultimately
delivered I felt like I had a better one
that was locked inside of me someplace
that I just couldn't access it and upon
review the next morning I discovered
that my final take of the video was
actually way better than I thought it
was it wasn't Perfect by any means but
it was still something that I felt like
I could be proud of now the timing of
this is kind of interesting because also
yesterday while I was navigating through
Twitter I ran across a video from a
young woman talking about why Zoomers
and Millennials do not want to work this
is a meme that I know is something that
a lot of people hold near and dear to
their heart but that I have found kind
of baffling since I first heard it and
this video was actually a great example
of why so this is the case this young
woman made basically that work is good
in that it brings feelings of
fulfillment and purpose but that
currently people just don't make enough
money to cover the cost of living to
cover the things they want to do and
meanwhile we are watching the world burn
very literally from climate change and
any number of other things and so it
just feels like the work is futile and I
do get where that comes from cuz
definitely it feels like there are
things going on in the world that are
far bigger than us that are very very
problematic not the least of which are
climate change and Global
conflicts but I find the logic that goes
into then saying you don't want to work
to be somewhat confusing because it's
like okay if you're not
working climate change and Global
conflicts are still a problem but now
you've removed that thing that gave you
purpose and that gave you fulfillment so
it's actually a worse situation than the
one that you started in and that is not
to say that all work is fulfilling and
that all work gives you a sense of
purpose there are definitely a lot of
jobs out there that are just Mindless
drudgery I mean that's part of why those
jobs exist people pay others to do the
work that they don't want to do
themselves all of us do that
but that doesn't mean that purpose
cannot be found within things like that
years ago I worked at a nonprofit here
in DC and I absolutely hated the job
despised it I had to dress up in
business casual which felt very onme I
had to navigate a bureaucracy of Egos
and people that I thought I was going in
to try and contribute to the world and
make it a better place and more often
than not we were arguing about like what
health plan we were going to use or who
exactly was responsible for which
initiative and how responsibilities were
being divided it felt so tedious and it
drove me crazy and So eventually I left
that job and I started doing flowarts
full-time and I know that to a lot of
people in the outside world that looks
like a victory that looks like I became
one of the Chosen Few that escaped the
machine thing is though I didn't escape
the machine at all see like all the
stuff that I didn't like about my old
job I still have to do not only that
because I'm a oneman shop for my YouTube
channel and the businesses associated
with it I have to do at least a dozen
other tasks that I didn't even know
existed that are just as annoying like
the whole reason that companies and
nonprofits have a massive role of
employees is because every single
employee specializes in a single task
that there's probably some unpleasant
stuff attached to you see ultimately the
problem was not the work the problem was
how I thought about it and my feelings
of connection to what the actual results
of that work were so like there are two
things that absolutely make my week
every single week the first one is when
I get to go into the dance studio for an
hour and I write a piece of choreography
to a song Sometimes I know exactly what
song I'm going to be working on going in
and sometimes I don't sometimes I just
see whatever is trending on on Instagram
and I pick whatever song kind of I feel
a good vibe from or that I can instantly
see in my head some choreography to go
along with it writing those pieces of
choreography is such a joy for me that
like I honestly have a hard time
sometimes sitting on them for a couple
days because I'm so excited about the
results I just can't wait to share them
with people and the other highlight of
my week well it's usually when I post
choreography from my PO dance classes
and I see a video that one of my
students has posted of themselves doing
that same choreography back in the day
people used to do this with tricks that
I had uploaded tutorials for as well but
in every case what I was watching was
somebody making a breakthrough
themselves using the tools that I had
put out there to the world and that just
filled me with a sense of warmth and joy
because I had instant an
incontrovertible evidence that something
that I had done had had a positive
impact on the world and somebody living
in it and the thing is doing both of
these things requires an enormous amount
of work whether it is trying to get X Y
and Z po dance moves to hit this count
and that count and that count or whether
it is teaching the class where I'm going
Point by Point through the choreography
that I've written in order to try and
help people get to the point where they
can post videos of themselves doing that
choreography too these are not things
that I necessarily look forward to but
the results are always things that make
me happy see this is why we call work
work because requires effort from us
sometimes it's physical sometimes it's
emotional sometimes it's both but either
which way we're putting ourselves in a
position where we have to be
uncomfortable for a while in order to
realize a great benefit down the road
and I think when people try and remove
that from their lives they're really
robbing themselves of something great I
mean sure I imagine that like traveling
the world and sipping wine and sitting
on beaches is something that uh would be
pretty fun but at the same time I don't
think that I would get that same deep
feeling like I've done something good
for the World by doing something like
that and that's that's no shade on
people for whom that is the goal it can
be really really hard to find something
that makes us feel fulfilled it's a lot
easier to find something that's going to
be fun in the short term but I think
that it is worth the effort the work to
find something that does make you feel
fulfilled because ultimately to me I
think that the benefit of work is
getting through those difficult and
unpleasant times teaches you a lot about
what your potential is it teaches you a
lot about the things that you can create
it teaches you a lot about the things
that you can work through every single
time that you learn a new po trick every
single time you take on a new creative
project there's going to be problems
that you have to solve there's going to
be moments when you're going to be
really frustrated and you have to work
through them and find out what's on the
other side and I personally think that
that is pretty awesome and I hope you do
too but for right now I am also going to
acknowledge that this comes with the
challenge of maintaining a balance
between work and play and right now it
is time for me to play cuz I have done
quite enough work this week thank you so
I'm going to sit down and spend some PO
for fun for the first time all week and
I cannot wait and I'll share some of it
with
[Music]
you
oh
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
it and of course to help my channel
[Music]
grow thanks so much for watching this
video would not be possible without the
kind of support of my patreon supporters
in particular I'd like to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all are awesome uh if
you'd like to check out some of my other
Vlogs on a variety of different topics I
will go ahead and include a link to a
playlist of those down in the
description as well as a link to my
patreon if you too would like to support
my work thanks once again for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
and I will see you with a new video real
soon take care now peace